hi my name is Lea Marie Johnson Terry
the tomboy is about a girl who makes
videos in her Shack and basically kind
of puts a little twist on beauty gurus
and kind of does the opposite of what
beauty gurus do and shows you how to put
makeup on her way and how to dress her
way which is very very country and hick
so it's always fun to shoot Harry
awesomenesstv said that they had a
sketch for me to do and I read it and I
fell in love with the character and I
just I've been doing it ever since and I
love doing I'm still doing it she's so
country I love the character I love
doing it cuz it's just so over the top
and I just love Terry the tomboy I am
shooting a movie next year in the spring
that comes out in September so I'm
really excited about that I might be a
little later might be like in October so
it's about it's called unhallowed
horseman but it's about the Headless
Horseman basically it's a twist on the
Headless Horseman so it's gonna be
exciting to shoot that it's a
full-length feature film so I started
out doing acting and singing when I was
around four four not four fourth grade I
was like 10 or 11 and so I started out
doing little talent shows and plays at
my school and then we moved out here
because my dad's in the Navy and we
started doing you know bigger stuff out
here it was just worked out that way
shooting Terry is still professional no
cameraman lighting everything's like the
same but it's just a long new media
YouTube videos are just shorter you know
and and they use the way that they edit
music
youth is really different from movies so
there's not much differences and it's
they're all the same when I love doing
both equally
I love Benny Rafi the fine brothers and
I think it's one of my favorite things
to do
reactivity is I just shot with Timothy
DeLaGhetto oh wow so uh I'm excited for
that to come out it'll come out in like
a few weeks so I'm really sad about that
and he's like one of my favorite
youtubers so so cool to meet him and
then now I'm working with him that was
awesome he's just like a really cool guy
he's got so much swag swag hey I don't
know why I just said swag but jenna
Marbles iJustine the fine brothers Smosh
the computer nerd jennxpenn so many I
like a lot of glozell